let's say the picture that i get the
injection when the
uh when the doctor fascinates
a vaccine for kovid19 that hasn't been
clinically approved
injected straight into the arm of evelyn
wu last week
the experimental chinese effort is still
in phase three clinical trials
significantly short of the typical
safety standards for vaccine development
this isn't a trial it's being given to
the public at large
i'm a little worried about the
experimental
uh stage three i think i was the one who
gathered tatties
yeah who um she's like the little mouse
evelyn is 20 years old and an economic
student at the university of birmingham
she plans to return to the uk in january
she signed up
last monday as soon as she read about
the vaccine online the first dose costs
26 pounds the second is due
next month i needed to sign some
contracts it told
it told me that it's very safe although
it's
on the stage three but for her
government approval is more important
than scientific i trusted china
and i think it's totally safe
the vaccine evelyn took was from cinevac
a beijing-based biotech company
which sky news visited in may it's
currently in phase 3 trials in turkey
brazil and the uae
and hasn't published results other phase
3 trials
from the uk and the us were temporarily
paused after participants became
seriously ill but china has publicly
recorded nothing similar
and has been steaming ahead since july
it's been giving vaccines to employees
as state-owned enterprises
ahead of foreign travel under emergency
use approval
these people were queuing in beijing
last week for another chinese vaccine
made by cinepharm
and the program is expanding several
cities and towns like this one
jiaxing and jojang province east china
have advertised the vaccines for local
residents
this is a local clinic where members of
the public can sign up to
get the vaccine even though it doesn't
have full scientific approval
the local disease control authorities
said they were doing this because winter
was coming
and with it the potential for a second
wave otherwise they would have waited
for some that will be rapid for others
it will be reckless
that speed gives some scientists pause
the obvious risk is that
it won't actually do what it's intended
to do that it won't protect people
in the way that they think it might and
then of course there's the
the possibility that side effects may
not be fully understood yet
the risks are real but evelyn and many
others in china
are willing to run them tom cheshire sky
news jojang province